[Musique]
un parfum de guerre froide plane sur la
scène internationale la russie va-t-elle
envahir l'ukraine et que fera washington
avec ses troupes massées dans la région
vladimir poutine et joe biden détiennent
les clés de ce suspense et pendant que
le ballet diplomatique satie au nom de
la paix la désinformation fait aussi
partie de l'arsenal des acteurs en
présence et c'est l'un ou en super où la
confusion s'installe
démarrage des restos bonjour bonjour
alexis tu nous parles depuis moscou un
point d'observation privilégié pour
analyser ce conflit qui génère de plus
en plus de tensions du jamais vu depuis
la guerre froide en fait et vu d'ici
avec la médiatisation qu'on en fait se
confirme l'impression que la russie est
l'acteur le plus actif sur le front de
la désinformation alors quelle est ta
perspective la thur si c'est un concours
ça serait ex-aequo en ce moment en tout
cas une course assez serré les deux là
où je suis comme vous l'avez dit de ma
fenêtre à moscou c'est une évidence on a
affaire à une surenchère médiatique qui
est nourri par des sources parfois
officiel parfois non officiels c'est
vrai que si on veut se fier aux faits
seulement on vit des moments hyper tendu
et franchement inédit regardons les
faits les faits sont les faits ils sont
incontestables il ya en ce moment cent
trente mille soldats russes près des
frontières de l'ue craint que ce soit du
côté russe ou du bélarus ils sont armés
jusqu'aux dents et on a le droit et on a
raison d'avoir peur de leur intention je
pense qu'on serait naïf ne pas réagir et
de post questionner et d'y voir une
simple ruse du kremlin mais au fil des
semaines on a j'allais dire un peu perdu
mais presque complètement perdu le fil
de la vérité parce qu'on la connaît pas
c'est ça qui est exceptionnel en ce
moment et cette notion
selon laquelle une attaque est imminente
on l'entend depuis noël du côté des
états unis
cette possibilité de l'armée de l'armée
devait devenir poutine marche même jusqu
à kiev ça vient d'où c'est sûr que ça
vient sûrement de scénarios ont été
élaborés de façon très sérieuse par le
pentagone c'est leur job au pentagone
d'envisager ce type de deux scénarios
mais on en a fait depuis quelques mois
le narratif officielle des etats-unis
jeudi aux états unis parce que c'est
moins le cas en europe sekana scénario
catastrophe on a un président bart
hayden qui est passé en moins d'un mois
à dire la taxe et demain matin en ont
finalement c'est peut-être plus tard
quand le sol sera gelé en fait le sol
est gelé
depuis déjà quelques semaines c'est la
première fois alexis que je suis en
russie que je constate que le jeu de la
désinformation envahi discours autant un
côté comme de l'autre donc moscou et
washington mais pas maroc quand même et
pas de mystère sur le fait que les
médias russes règle générale sont
alignés sur la position officielle du
kremlin qu'en pensent les russes de tout
seul les citoyens que tu as rencontré au
fil de thé reportage comment il arrive à
faire la part des choses il ya un
attachement viscéral en russie chez le
russe moyen pour l'ukraine j'ai jamais
me rencontrer une personne sur le
terrain dans la crise actuelle ou même
avant qui en veut aux ukrainiens qui ne
leur souhaite pas là et dans ce cas de
malaise public à nice elle devrait
savoir qu'il ne commet pas de
nourriture
mais ce conflit sert aux médias du
kremlin un prétexte pour démoniser
l'occident comme il l'a toujours fait
mais de faire encore plus et des
émissions cultes ici un des shows
d'affaires publiques des grands rendez
vous télévisuel entre autres le dimanche
soir qui servent exactement à ça de
planter la ligne officielle du kremlin à
tête des gens sans aucune nuance on
ouvre l'émission comme la semaine
dernière avec des éditoriaux en faisant
le temps sosa de l'ukraine pour nous
diviser de nos frères ukrainiens vous
comprenez pourquoi il faut s'en méfier
pourquoi la russie est en danger
pourquoi des troupes à la frontière est
situé via versailles je suis ambitieux
je pense merci à savoir hystérie ni à
droite ni à gauche et on a seulement au
claé ni les plus rigoureux programme
et parallèlement on a des opérations
assez ciblées sur les médias sociaux des
sites internet des comptes qui répandent
aussi des rumeurs comme ça c'était du
côté de washington selon lesquelles les
américains préparent eux aussi des
provocations spécifique même des
attaques chimiques
quand j'ai vu ça
c'est tout ce qu'on peut lire en ce
moment
et de la même façon que beaucoup de gens
en amérique du nord sont convaincus
aujourd'hui que la russie veut attaquer
l'ukraine en fait je peux a bien dit non
mais doit avoir un effet auprès de la
population mais les russes ici pense
qu'il est nécessaire de répliquer à
l'otan et toi t'as marins dans tout ça
en tant que journaliste comment tu
arrives à parvenir aux faits bruts à
faire abstraction des spins à gauche à
droite qui te proviennent des deux côtés
de la médaille j'y arrive pas toujours
c'est la vérité françois et honnête
comme journalistes ont dit tout le temps
mais plus on lit qu on se renseigne plus
on développe un regard éclairé un sens
critique mais faut être très très
prudent en ce moment moi mon rôle en
russie on s'empêche pas une médias
russes jusqu'au là pour faire des
enquêtes
déterrer la vérité sur certains dossiers
mais surtout de vérifier l'humeur et de
contrevérités les affirmations
et ne pas les tenir pour acquis mais
c'est presque impossible de le faire
aussi j'ai le devoir en ce moment
spécifiquement depuis quelques semaines
de faire un ménage qui permit aux nîmois
l'expression dans un bordel
d'information c'est vraiment ça enfin en
dormir la nuit elle savait tout le monde
et son chien sont extraits ça en anglais
à grenoble
prétend savoir ce qui se passe dans la
tête de vladimir poutine combien
d'articles chez lui où on dit what côté
one
la vérité c'est qu'on le sait pas et je
pense que comme journaliste on n'aime
pas ça mais faut être capable de
répondre on ne le sait pas et de partir
à partir de là de travailler dans le
contexte de tête à tête militarisé comme
ça entre l'occident et la russie de
comprendre et d'expliquer aux gens quels
sont les intérêts de chaque partie parce
que ça joue beaucoup et ça motive
beaucoup les actions militaires qu'on
voit en ce moment il d'aller sur le
terrain
on a une équipe en ce moment
radio-canada réussi à pénétrer à donetsk
est un territoire séparatiste pro-russe
extrêmement ferme et parler aux gens
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils
veulent se joindre à la russie ce que
leur territoire pourrait servir de base
pour envahir la russie bref d'aller
vérifier ce qu'on pense savoir que rien
comme le terrain il n'y a rien comme
comme le vrai monde ces salaires ah si
banal à dire mais c'est toujours le cas
ça fait pas des reportages ça peut pas
des politiciens mais disons que ça fait
des reportages qui est fort et qui donne
aux canadiens dans mon col le portrait
le plus le plus honnête possible de la
situation qui est très complexe où est
très complexe en effet mais la beauté à
travers tout ça tamara sais que tu
arrive toujours à nous expliquer avec
brio ce qui se passe là bas malgré la
complexité des dossiers merci encore
pour ce passage au décrypteurs